also das ist ein formbarer kleber soweit
ich es jetzt okay ich geb dir das mal
komme dass diese dinger soll alle mit
diesem kleber zusammen geklebt worden
sein
deswegen juli ich würd sagen ich lebe
jetzt einfach mal hier auf deine
colaflasche einem trip taste darauf hey
was geht ab und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video ja leute ich auf
natürlich euch geht es gut
ihr seht schon wir haben umgebaut also
wir haben uns wirklich ein paar gedanken
gemacht ich wollte auch mal was neues
ausprobieren weil ich nie so ganz eklig
mit dem hintergrund zufrieden war mit
dem ganzen look und so die kamera ist
zwar noch die gleiche wir haben paar
andere einstellung und der hintergrund
ist auch neue beziehungsweise nimmt eine
neue form an die wir noch ein bisschen
weiter ausweiten möchten also da fehlt
noch einiges wenn ihr irgendwelche ideen
habt schreibt gerne in die kommentare
wir haben überlegt noch so ein paar
bilder und so so lustige fotos aber das
kommt auf jeden fall noch in den
nächsten tagen kosten können wir gern
mal in die kommentare schreiben wie es
findet wir machen heute weiter mit einem
neuen unboxing video und zwar habe ich
mir nach langer zeit mal wieder amazon
gadgets rausgesucht lustige gadgets für
unter 10 euro mit denen eigentlich jeder
etwas anfangen kann und wir testen die
heute wir schauen uns erst mal vorher
haben wir für die gut sind und dann habe
ich die hat einfach mal bestellt das ist
jetzt ganz viele pakete wir sind
allerdings auch noch eine menge sachen
drin die für ein anderes video genötigt
sein ich habe keine ahnung was drin ist
deswegen checken wir es vor dem ersten
clip ab und ich würde sagen euch viel
spaß dabei
der mini staubsauger wird mit zwei
doppelte batterien betrieben und einfach
der knopf ein und ausgeschaltet der mpk
105 mini ist sehr leise überzeugt mit
hoher kaufkraft und lässt krümel auf dem
tisch im nu verschwinden er ist sehr
kompakt und findet daher platz auf jedem
tisch und in jeder tasche
also ich habe keine ahnung woher dieser
staubsauger drin sein soll
der muss ja wirklich extrem mini sein
aber ich habe den so gefeiert dass ich
den direkt bestellt habe ich meinen
heute sind wir mal ehrlich wer kennt es
nicht man sitzt am schreibtisch oder so
und krümelt oder frühstück da was weiß
ich dann kann es einfach diesen mini
staubsauger nehmen und dein tisch
säubern
das ist doch genial oder jetzt muss ich
den hut nur irgendwo drin finden
[Musik]
ich dachte schon so hey das war jetzt
einfach das letzte paket leute das hier
ist das gute teil ich finde es sieht aus
wie sonne kleine wachstums oder so für
hrworks könnte es auch sein aber es ist
natürlich ein mini staubsauger also das
ding ist wirklich extrem kleine warte
mal kurzer vergleich wir haben ja selber
hier sonst geburt war also hier passt
natürlich deutlich mehr aber ich bin mal
gespannt wir brauchen jetzt batterien
und dann kann es auch schon los fahren
fünf euro 90 hat das nur gekostet ich
verlinke euch alle sachen in der video
beschreibung die könnt ihr einfach
kaufen wenn ihr euch für interessiert
und ist natürlich viel geht links also
ich profitiert ein bisschen von der
seite nämlich unterstützen wollt kauft
ihr machen einen link wir waren mal kurz
batterien rhein von meiner lieblings
marke die machen auch alles also jetzt
fehlen natürlich nur noch krümel oder so
ne scheiße sagt keinen hunger hat und
allen guten die frage prüfen
ich mache jetzt mal an und dann bin ich
gespannt ob es sich lohnt hinzukaufen
und ob er das vor allem
roman
alter
egal zehn von zehn punkte oder also der
hat das optimal direkt weggezogen
heftiges teil kann ich euch auf jeden
fall empfehlen also wenn ihr so ein
arbeitsplatz machen so und manchmal so
ein bisschen dreck macht kauft euch das
ding ist wirklich günstig fünf euro
ich glaube ich da kann man nicht mehr
kann beschweren kann man sich ja
normalerweise eher weniger und wir
machen weiter auch gemacht
naja das ist dann das problem meist
fällt wieder raus als wir müssten dann
direkt und lernen
[Musik]
ok also das habe ich auch direkt
bestellt wir haben ja schon mal jährlich
juli ist übrigens immer noch hinter der
kamera hallo hallo also wir haben ja
schon mal ein unzerstörbares ladekabel
getestet ein bisschen erinnert mich das
daran also es gibt halt auch wiederum
ladekabel deswegen wahrscheinlich
hier haben wir das gute gerät das ist
ein kabel das man also wer kennt es
nicht du hast ein android handy du hast
ein iphone und dann immer dieses trio
horstmann kabel für mich manchmal fragen
nicht mit diesem kabel ist dieses
problem gegessen also glaube ich
zumindest das sei denn das ist schlecht
wir haben hier schon einmal das kabel
und hier dann die verschiedenen
anschlüsse einmal iphone dann hier so
ein mini usb dingen usb c wie auch immer
man nennt sie sind ach so genau das sind
magneten mir das heißt du kannst jetzt
dieses kabel gute qualität ich glaube
das hat knapp nur unter zehn euro kostet
das ist teil des schon ein bisschen
teurer als staubsauger bald günstiger
langes kabel aber da kannst du nicht
mehr kann also ohne scheiß wenn man ein
neues iphone ladekabel kauf bist du auch
bei 20 euro im laden kümmern und du
kannst dann hier einfach dieses ding
drauf magnet ihren sagt man das so
kompass auf und ab und ab ins iphone der
magnet ist auch stark genug so dass das
nicht praktisch jetzt wieder abfließt
und das ist schlecht ja kummer hat
funktioniert also der magnet könnte ein
bisschen stärker sein trotzdem ich würde
sagen man muss ja nicht viel zu erklären
wir machen weiter mit dem nächsten und
ich denke dass wir auch nein wenn die
temperaturen steigen und du eine
langanhaltende erfrischung brauchst
wirst du dieses gadget zu schätzen
wissen
das kühlen der handtuch eignen sich
nämlich perfekt für outdoor sport und
freizeitaktivitäten in den einzigartigen
kühlungseffekt zu aktivieren muss man
das handtuch lediglich mit wasser nass
machen es aus bringen und dann in die
luft schlagen
nun kann man das kühlende tuch
beispielsweise einfach um den hals legen
und so eine sofortige erfrischung
verspüren okay also
hier haben wir ein handtuch was
praktisch immer kühlt also du musst es
zwar nass machen aber es bleibt dann
kühl also an sich die idee ist ich bin
mal gespannt ob das funktioniert ich
habe es natürlich bestellt und wo war
das jetzt noch mal hier okay das ist
aber klein oder also ich habe mir das
irgendwie ein bisschen größer
vorgestellt muss ich sagen das ja mal
das problem hast du sachen man sieht im
internet bekommt die dann und dann sind
hier einfach voll mini aber gut mal
schauen sagte mir gerade ich mir sicher
wie teuer das war auf jeden fall unter
zehn euro ja das ding ist halt ein
wirkliches handtuch ist es nicht das ist
mehr sonne also irgendwie denke ich
dabei direkt an fahrrad fahren
warum das hier mitgeliefert wird weiß
ich nicht genau
ich würde sagen wir machen das jetzt mal
nass und laut dem video soll das ja
einfach die ganze zeit kühl bleiben
das heißt wir warten einmal kurz und
schauen ob es immer noch kühl ist das
natürlich sehr nice wenn du so ein
handtuch hast was die ganze kühl bleibt
gehe mal kurz in die küche
okay leute also hier könnt ihr sehen
ich habe es jetzt hier immer nass
gemacht es ist wirklich wirklich extrem
kalt muss ich sagen also schön kühl
ich muss nur einmal um nacken und dann
warten wir mal kurz auch wenn das
natürlich sehr sehr kalt ist muss man
schon sagen normalerweise jedes andere
handel werde jetzt war mal schauen ob
das jetzt wirklichkeit bleibt ich kann
es nicht so ganz klar weil woran soll
das liegen
das regelt auch der lacht einmal weil
ich dann immer daran riechen in sachen
bisschen komisch riecht das aber es ist
schon auch kühl fast firma will fühlt
nur ganz kühl nicht mehr aber andere
hand also ich weiß nicht ich lasse das
handeln jetzt einfach mal um und wir
machen weiter mit dem nächsten produkt
und dann kann ich euch am ende noch ein
fazit dazu nennen
jetzt kommt wie ist doch mal dieser von
pippi lampe wie soll dieser von bibi
lang schon konrad spezialkleber jacke
ziemlich konrad spezialkleber konrad
spezialkleber leute einmal daumen nach
oben alle die das känguru ist der erste
formbare kleber der welt der zu einem
haltbaren unflexiblen silikon gummi
aushärtet so ermöglicht so eine neue art
dinge zu reparieren und zu verbessern
durch die patentierte und fortgeschickt
diesem video das sieht einfach so
kaus wir alle in eigentlich zusammen
gerne jeden tag leben
also das ist ein formbarer kleber soweit
ich das jetzt ok juli gibt ihr das mal
komme dass diese dinger soll alle mit
diesem kleber zusammen geklebt worden
sein
außerdem eignet sich so hohen plastik
beispielsweise auch bei spielzeug der
fall ist schnell und einfach zu
reparieren
durch diese funktion kann das gadget
zudem die zahlreichen haushalten
eingesetzt werden jedoch kann man nicht
nur die regierung sondern auch
praktische dinge der kopfhörer oder
lautsprecher und comedy machen damit
halt so auch so praktisch wenn irgendwas
kaputt geht im haushalt kannst du das
sammelt wieder tapen wenn irgendwo hin
griff abbricht muss halt diesen dummen
kleber also so wird das jetzt im video
vorgestellt hier haben wir auch schon
das produkt handtuch ist dicker handtuch
ist immer noch kühl das hier ist der
modewelt blue glaube das hat so abt euro
gekostet oder so einmal wie man den mal
raus wir haben drei verschiedene
parcours
ich hab ja also es ist jetzt nicht
besonders viel kleber den man die hatte
also eigentlich ist es extrem wenig muss
ich sagen von mir nehmen einfach mal den
schwarzen hier war alter also das ist
der kleber und jetzt lebe ich mal
irgendwelche dinge aneinander kleiner
negativer aspekt deine hände werden halt
voll schwarz also heute noch mal von
vorne
wir haben das hier in dieser verpackung
drin man nimmt es raus und hat 30
minuten das irgendwie zu formen
irgendwas damit zu machen und dann muss
man 24 schon warten und das ding ist
bombenfest und hat irgendwas miteinander
verbunden oder dient als irgendein bügel
sonstiges deswegen juli ich würd sagen
ich lebe jetzt einfach mal hier oben auf
deine colaflasche meine youtube taste
drauf wir müssen die jetzt hier stehen
das inliner juni kannst du nicht mehr
von trinken die nächsten sind schön und
dann testen was damit passiert ob man
das dann einfach so hochheben kann
natürlich auch noch zwei weitere hier
kommen damit mache ich auch noch
irgendwas so sieht es aus also
eigentlich wieso knete meiste ja und ich
kann mir vorstellen dass es wirklich
irgendwann so richtig fest wird hat eine
gute idee komme hier wird auch so ein
headset gezeigt was daran geklebt wird
irgendwo ich mache mir einfach dass so
eine halterung für meinen ps4 headset
das noch leisten
[Musik]
wir sind uns dann in 24 stunden wieder
und zum handtuch kann ich sagen ist
immer noch kühl also auch das produkt
ganz neues also ich weiss nicht braucht
man jetzt unbedingt weil so richtig
kasse ist es auch nie muss ich sein
ja ich bin auch leute was geht ab
willkommen zurück 24 stunden später
und wie ihr sehen könnt hier steht keine
cola flasche mehr
hier steht noch die tasse mit ein
bisschen kleber an der seite und unten
drunter habe ich schon versucht beste
make-up zu wischen
ich war einkaufen bin wieder gekommen
ich komme mir einfach ein lautes ist
diese taste von der colaflasche
runtergefallen auf den tisch auf dem
boden dieser henkel abbauen von meiner
heißgeliebten icahns storm brought you
tube dass alle da wir ja wirklich so
aufgeregt was ist denn das für kleber
und jetzt kommen wir weiter hier
kümmerte wären da hinten noch diese
rezept halterung gemacht da wir uns mal
angucken was daraus geworden ist ich bin
jetzt wirklich mal gespannt ob man damit
arbeiten kann
okay leute checa diesmal ab ich würde
sagen man sich mal kanton sagt ist sehr
fest ich glaube nicht dass man das so
ist man kann es nicht wie sie abreißen
ich weiß nicht vielleicht ist das halt
ein bisschen zu dick also das
funktioniert doch halbwegs gehabt ich
habe irgendwann mal probiert das ist
runtergefallen herzlich wahrscheinlich
auch besser vor müssen trotzdem dass
kate wirklich gut war kommen hier können
sie das ganze regale schicken dieser
change age geschichte was geht ab na ja
also kleber auf jeden fall muss man
richtig anwenden bei der taste und der
kohle hat sich geklappt keinen plan wie
sollte ich hoffe dass wir gott euch
gefallen last sehr sehr gern daumen nach
oben streckt die nächste news abgekommen
werden es kommt viel neisser scheiß
jetzt hier und dann würde ich sagen
danke dass du schon abonniert auf jeden
fall alle vielleicht den kanal checkt
auch mal ein zwei kanal alex baur ab ins
normale haut rein